On January 9th North and South Korea
engaged in high-level talks for the
first time in two years instead of
addressing North Korea's nuclear program
the two sides discussed less contentious
issues such as North Korea's
participation in the upcoming Winter
Olympics in Pyeongchang while dialogue
can reduce unnecessary tension and even
serve as a way to gather more
information about North Korea's
perspectives and strategy there could be
drawbacks of Washington and Seoul are
not careful first North Korea's
willingness to talk about minor issues
is not an indicator that Pyongyang's
position on nuclear weapons is softening
there is no situation under which North
Korea gives up its nuclear weapons
through negotiation second Kim might be
trying to improve relations with Seoul
as a way of driving a wedge in the
us-rok Alliance and there's a risk of
this given that the United States
prefers a strategy of escalating
pressure whereas South Korea prioritizes
maximum engagement now more than ever
the United States and South Korea must
continue to coordinate their approach
towards North Korea what do you think
about the potential thawing of relations
between North and South Korea let us
know in your comments also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI